- Welcome, everybody.
I'm Maurice Samuels, the director
of the Yale Program for
the Study of Anti-Semitism,
and it's my great pleasure
to welcome you today
to this talk by Richard Hurowitz.
Richard is a writer, investor,
and the publisher of
the "Octavian Report,"
a quarterly magazine
devoted to politics,
economics, and culture.
His writing has appeared
in "The New York Times,"
the "Financial Times,"
"The Wall Street Journal,"
"The Times" of London,
"The Jerusalem Post,"
and many other publications.
His new book, "In the
Garden of the Righteous:
"The Heroes Who Risked Their Lives
"to Save Jews During the Holocaust,"
was published just last
week by HarperCollins
and has received a lot of attention.
The "Kirkus" starred review calls it,
"A fresh, engrossing contribution
"to the literature of the Holocaust,
"focusing on heroics rather than despair."
Richard received his BA in history
from Yale in 1995, magna cum laude,
and was elected to Phi Beta Kappa.
He earned his JD from Columbia Law School,
where he was a Harlan Fiske Stone Scholar.
He lives in New York City with his family,
and his son Asher is
currently a first year at Yale
in Berkeley College,
so here's how it's gonna work today.
Richard will speak for
about 30 or 40 minutes.
Then we'll open it up to questions.
Please submit your questions to me
using the Q&A function at
the bottom of your screen.
You can submit the questions
at any time during the lecture,
and I'll ask them to Richard
during the Q&A period.
We can't actually see or hear you,
so that's the only way
to communicate with us,
and we'll wrap up at 6:00 p.m.,
so now I will hand it over to Richard.
- Thank you. Well, thank you, Maury.
Thank you, Vanessa,
and it's a really great pleasure
and very special to be here.
Yale is a very, very special place for me,
an important part of my life,
and as I'll talk in a moment,
kind of where this book started,
and it remains a special part of my life,
and hopefully, I will be up
there later in the semester.
As Maury mentioned,
I have a personal reason for being there,
which is my son just started,
and is doing far more interesting things
than I ever did there,
but anyway, thank you all
for joining this conversation,
and I'm a big admirer of, Maury, your work
and the Yale Program for
the Study of Anti-Semitism,
which I believe is the only such program
in the United States,
so it's really important
work that's being done there,
so let me see.
There, okay, so this is
the origin of the book.
On the left is something
you'll all recognize,
which is Sterling,
and on the right is the Holocaust Museum.
I put these images up
because the Holocaust Museum on the mall
opened its doors when I was at Yale,
and my family has been in this country
for many generations, so
predating the Holocaust,
although my wife's family,
my mother-in-law actually
is a Holocaust survivor,
but we, like a lot of American Jews,
made the pilgrimage down
to the museum on the right,
and anybody who's ever
been through the museum
knows that it's an
extraordinarily difficult,
enervating experience, intentionally so.
The artifacts are very difficult to see.
I remember,
and as I've been discussing
the book with a lot of people,
this is something that
seems to have a huge impact
on anyone who sees it,
which is this pile of shoes that is there
from, you know, victims of the Shoah.
Many of them, when you look closely,
are in children's sizes,
so we always have to remember
that of the 6 million who died,
1 1/2 million were children,
and anyway, for me, it
was an extraordinarily,
almost overwhelming, very
upsetting experience,
and I came out into a room that was there
that was dedicated to the
very small number of people
who tried to do something
to stop the Holocaust,
to stop Nazism, to stop totalitarianism,
and immediately saw these pictures,
and particularly the one on the left,
and this young man, Alexander Schmorell,
for some reason, this picture
stuck with me at the time.
I still remember seeing it.
He was, I guess, around the
same age I was at the time,
and he was a medical student,
and he was part of something
called the White Rose,
which was a small group of
students that was started by,
on the right, you see,
actually four of them.
He's actually, his face is blocked,
but the girl in the
middle is Sophie Scholl,
and she was an undergraduate
at the University of Munich.
Her brother, on the left, Hans Scholl,
was really the founder of the movement,
and they were very idealistic students.
The Scholls came from
a very unusual family.
They were from the same
town as Einstein, Ulm.
Their father was an ardent
believer in liberal democracy,
but they were also devout Christians,
and he believed in freedom
and told them that, you know,
they should do whatever they can
to stand up for other people.
I had the privilege
of meeting her best
friend, who was Jewish,
who told me, you know,
all about, you know,
the kind of idealism of the family.
They were also notable,
so what they started doing
was circulating leaflets
to other students,
but also to just, you know,
they would put them in, and
mail them to random people
around Munich and throughout Germany
talking about that this is
not the Germany we know.
They quoted Plato. They quoted Aristotle.
They quoted Chinese philosophers,
and they tried to foment
a uprising against Hitler.
This went on for a year.
They put graffiti in Munich,
and Schmorell, the guy with the pipe,
he actually is among the first people
to publicize the Holocaust.
In the second leaflet, he
wrote that at that point,
300,000 Jews had been killed
in the most bestial way,
so these were just, like,
wonderful people, young people,
and then, unfortunately, one day,
they were handing leaflets
out in the university,
and they came to the top of a staircase,
and Sophie realized that she
had a lot of extra leaflets,
and there was an atrium, and
she threw them in the air.
They started floating down.
A maintenance man, who was an ardent Nazi,
saw them, locked the door.
They were arrested.
Hitler personally sent his judge
down from Berlin.
They were put on trial,
and they were executed,
and right before Hans
was executed, you know,
he shouted out in the,
it was very famous now,
"Long live freedom!"
And Sophie, when she was on trial,
made a comment.
She said, "Everyone
believes what we believe,
"but everyone is afraid to say it,"
and unfortunately, that was not
the case, as we'll get into.
They were very (indistinct).
There are many, many schools in Germany
that were very well known in Germany,
not so much outside of Germany,
because people want to believe, you know,
this is how everyone behaved,
but it was very, very rare,
but to me, it was also, at that time,
a bit of a balm and an antidote
to the horror of what I had
experienced at the museum,
and the story stayed with me,
and, you know, I was a
history major at Yale,
and I actually thought about
writing my senior essay
about the White Rose,
but I realized I didn't know German,
and I had a great experience.
I wrote with Donald Kagan
on Alexander the Great,
but the story stayed with me,
and I ended up writing about it
a number of years ago,
but, you know, about five years ago
for "The New York Times,"
I wrote on the 75th
anniversary of their execution,
like, sort of memorial,
and it's telling their story
and saying that we
should really honor them,
and the response that I had
was just so enormous and so positive,
and as you all know, the
Internet is a very scary place.
There was not one negative
comment about them,
so I started writing up
stories of the righteous,
and I had the same experience
with a number of articles I wrote
in "The New York Times" and "The Journal"
and the "L.A. Times,"
and "The Daily Beast,"
and so I decided to turn them into a book.
The thing about it is that rescue
is a very under-covered,
under-focused-on area
for a variety of reasons,
and it's unusual
because people really have
seemed to respond to the stories.
I mean, it's not just my experience,
but, like, there was a movie
called "Schindler's List"
that did pretty well, both
critically and commercially,
so right after the war,
and I have here another Yale image.
This is a picture of
the Milgram experiments.
You know, after the war,
people were very interested
in the evil that happened.
They were interested in
why people collaborated.
They were not so interested
in those small number
of people who helped,
and there was also a view,
in the first generation
of survivors, you know,
many of whom actually were
not rescued and had gone,
had horrible experiences
in concentration camps,
that you not distort the record
by focusing on something that was so rare.
I put a statistic up here,
so Yad Vashem in Jerusalem,
and their criterion are very stringent,
has recognized order of
magnitude 27,000 people
with the title Righteous
Among the Nations,
which seems like a large number,
but that's out of 500 million people
that were in Europe at the time,
so even if you multiply by 10,
it's still a vanishingly
small number of people.
If you were to fill Madison Square Garden
with a random number of the 500 million,
you'd have approximately
one rescuer there,
so unfortunately, you know,
people always knew Raoul
Wallenberg, you know,
and then, after the movie,
they know Oskar Schindler.
but there's been very
little attention paid
to any of the other rescuers.
Some people know the story of Denmark,
and the next generation of survivors,
one of the leaders of which
was a friend of mine, Abe Foxman,
who was the longtime head of the ADL,
had more of an interest
in focusing on righteousness,
and the Righteous Among
the Nations program
has been part of Yad
Vashem from its founding.
It's one of its core missions.
Just to pause for a moment,
the title of my book "In the
Garden of the Righteous,"
is actually a real place in Jerusalem,
and the reason, what it is,
is when someone is
recognized as righteous,
they plant a tree
in the garden there,
which is now almost a forest,
and it's a very powerful
experience to walk through it,
and, you know, it's a
very beautiful sort of
and very poetic place
and gesture that's made.
You know, for me, I think
there's a handful of reasons
that it's very important to
actually focus on rescue,
and there was the purpose of the book,
and I tried to talk about this
in my introduction and conclusion.
One is out of gratitude
because I think there's,
it's very important that, you know,
it's both a Jewish value
and a humanist value
to say thank you to people
who did among the greatest acts, I think,
in the history of humanity, truly,
and risked their lives, often
for people they didn't know,
sometimes for people
they didn't even like,
and just were unbelievably heroic
at probably the worst moment in history,
and a rabbi, who was one of the founders
of the movement to recognize the righteous
also said, "There's a historical injustice
"that we all know the names
"of Himmler and Goering and Hitler,
"but we don't know the names
"of people like Sousa Mendes or Sugihara,"
and so it's an attempt to correct that.
I also think there are enormous
lessons that we can learn
from why people did
this, how they did this.
Since the Second World War,
there have been more than 40 genocides.
We're living through a moment of horrific
war crimes being committed
in more than one place.
I mean, obviously, in Ukraine,
you have a million Uighurs
in concentration camps.
500,000 people lost their
lives in the Syrian civil war,
and there's also goodness
going on right now,
and I think we need to learn that,
and the lessons also are
relevant for our own society
to try to make it a better place,
and certainly, to try to avoid
anything like the Holocaust
or the Second World War
from happening again,
and then, I think there's also,
it is important, not just for children,
but for anybody who had
the experience I had,
that, you know, a friend of mine
kind of called "The Righteous"
a banister you could hold to
learn about the Holocaust,
and so for many people, you know,
when you start to talk about
6 million Jews dead, you know,
hundreds of thousands
of other people killed,
50 million people during
the Second World War,
it's very difficult,
and so a way of sort of, you know,
beginning to think about
and understand the Holocaust
and combat things like Holocaust denial
is to talk about the good.
I mean, I remember Mister
Rogers, after 9/11,
they brought him out of retirement,
and then he was asked,
"How do we talk about
this with the children?"
And he said, "We need
to look to the helpers,"
and so I think that is important,
and so that's another reason
why I think these stories need to be told
and need to be remembered,
so, you know, one question,
like, why did people do this?
So there was some work done.
This picture is another amazing
person. He's in my book.
He was the cousin of the Trocmés,
who were the pastor and his wife
in a town called Le Chambon
I'll talk about in a moment,
but he was a teacher in his early 30s.
He taught both adolescents
and small children.
He was, like, the equivalent of,
like, the head of the college at Yale,
and he gave, he lost his life
'cause there was a,
like, a Gestapo roundup,
and he was sent to a
concentration camp and gassed,
but he was, he wrote home
even after he'd been arrested,
but before that, he'd found his calling
that helping people, helping
children, hide children
was really what he was
put on this earth to do,
so there was some study done.
There was one pretty systematic study
that was done by two Holocaust survivors,
a husband and a wife,
who were also psychologists, the Oliners.
They wrote a book called
"The Altruistic Personality,"
and they looked at all
different kinds of reasons
people might have done this.
It's not entirely satisfying.
Their main conclusion, believe it or not,
was that the only
correlation they really found
was with parental discipline,
so people who disciplined their children
in a loving, rational way,
who explained what the
child had done wrong,
where the punishment was commensurate
with what they did wrong,
they tended to be more rescuers
as opposed to people
who developed more of an
authoritarian personality
because their parents
would fly off the handle
and corporal punishment and all of that,
and I think my,
just a few lessons that
I've seen from this
that I think can build on that
is that there's no question
that the single most important thing
that made someone into a rescuer
was having a strong parent role model
or both parents
or some other, you know,
figure in their life
that taught them at a
very young age, you know,
to be tolerant of others,
that bigotry was wrong,
that bullying was wrong,
and also, they tended to
come from very loving homes
where they were valued,
and this led to strong self-esteem,
and that's very important
because another correlation
is that most of the rescuers
were people who had very
strong inner compass
and were willing to listen to themselves
when everything else was
kind of falling apart,
so one lesson, for sure, is,
like, how people grow up,
the home they grow up in
has a huge impact on
the people they become
and the values that they
have and their ability,
their willingness to speak out.
Educational attainment, I
say this to what's probably,
what is definitely a
highly educated audience,
completely noncorrelated.
Most rescuers had a belief
in something greater than themselves.
The single most common
was religion of all sorts.
Could have been something
like liberal democracy or nonviolence.
These were people, though,
when I say religion of real faith,
they really internalized
the teachings of, you know,
love thy neighbor as thyself,
the parable of the Good Samaritan.
They were not people who
were interested in the church
for signs of external piety.
People who were in creative professions
or who were in careers
that brought them into
international, you know,
a lot of contact with other
people all around the world
also tended to be rescuers,
and a couple of other things just to note
that are kind of universal.
They're almost universally modest.
Over and over,
and I've looked at hundreds if
not thousands of these cases,
they would say things like,
"I just did what any normal
person would've done.
"I just did the decent thing,"
and, of course, that's not
true, but that is sincere.
I don't think there's
false modesty in that,
and there's an unusual number of them
that actually suffered for what they did.
Oskar Schindler had rocks thrown at him
in Germany after the war,
and reasons for that,
and I've talked to a lot
of experts about this,
one was, you know,
I mean, anti-Semitism
was a very real thing,
and it didn't go away just
because the Nazis lost the war.
People also questioned people for,
like, bringing potential
risk to the community
because there was often
collective punishment for this.
Behind the Iron Curtain,
you also had the phenomenon
where a lot of rescuers
who had often been in the underground
where the Allies were were persecuted.
There's also institutional
anti-Semitism there,
so that was sort of, you know,
a number of people who
didn't get any recognition
until after the fall of the Berlin Wall,
and then, I think the single
biggest reason, though,
that people were sort of
tormented after the war
was they're inconvenient to people.
They go against the ability to say,
"I couldn't have done anything"
because they did do something,
and they actually, as rare as they were,
they're sort of an object lesson in that,
and, you know, Hitler had a secretary.
After the war,
she was walking by a
quote from Sophie Scholl,
and she realized that she
had been the same age as her,
you know, during the war,
and when she saw that, she actually said,
you know, "I actually had
no excuse for what I did,"
so I think the rescuers,
people resented very much what they did
because it kind of put the lie to the idea
that everyone just had
to go along with it,
even if you were, you know, against it.
I'll talk about a couple of, a few,
just to give you a little,
like, tidbits from the book
to, hopefully, you'll
wanna read more about it,
so I'll just talk about
a few different rescuers
that I cover,
so this gentleman,
Aristides de Sousa Mendes,
a review in "The
Christian Science Monitor"
by a reviewer that I
actually, I don't know,
but I've been a fan of,
so I was happy to see him review it.
He actually called him the
breakout star of the book,
and when people ask me like,
"Who was your favorite?"
That's a very hard question,
but he's among my favorites.
He's very powerful story.
He's believed to have had
the largest single rescue
by a single individual
during the Holocaust.
Some people put the number
as many as 30,000 people.
He was a aristocratic
aristocrat from Portugal.
He was a twin.
His brother was the successful one.
He became foreign minister.
Sousa Mendes was one of these diplomats
that was an amazing entertainer,
so there were all kinds of amazing people
always in and out of his house.
He had a enormous family.
He had 15 children.
He was a devout Catholic.
He believed he was actually,
as many Portuguese are,
a descendant of Jews,
but, like, hundreds and
hundreds of years ago, earlier,
and he was a humanitarian,
and he found himself posted
in Bordeaux in June of 1940
as the consul general,
and at that time, as many of you know,
there was a huge exodus
as the Nazis came in,
invaded France down from Paris,
millions and millions of people were in,
like, the worst traffic
jam in human history,
and the Luftwaffe was overhead, you know,
people literally would
see their family members
killed by machine gun fire,
and they would go door to door
once they got to the South
'cause people wanted to get the,
really, the only way out was through Spain
and into Portugal and beyond,
which were two neutral countries,
and people went door to door to consulates
just looking for visa.
You actually need more than one visa,
but you needed an exit visa,
and everyone slammed the door,
including the United States of America,
and Portugal, too, had Salazar,
who was the dictator of Portugal,
was an enormously complicated guy.
He was sympathetic, at that
point, to the fascists,
but he really didn't want a refugee crisis
because he was terrified
of losing neutrality
and being pulled into the war,
so he sent out orders
to all of his diplomats:
"No refugees are allowed
into Portugal or into Spain,
"and particularly not Jews."
Sousa Mendes was in his consulate,
and there were literally
thousands of people outside,
tens of thousands of people in the street,
and he went out one day,
and he met a rabbi, a young
rabbi who had come from Antwerp,
and he had been posted in Belgium before,
and the rabbi had a large family,
and Sousa Mendes was basically,
had sent most of his children home.
He just had his two oldest
sons with him and his nephew,
and he said to the rabbi,
"Why don't you come
spend the night in the...
"Don't sleep on the street;
come to the consulate,"
and they had this, like,
heart-to-heart conversation,
and Sousa Mendes said, you know,
"I can't really issue visas,
but I think I can," you know,
and he had actually done it
in violation earlier
already for a couple people,
and he said, you know,
"Let me give visas to
you and your family,"
and the rabbi said to him,
"I can't accept your offer.
"I can't leave all of my people here.
"I can't leave everybody on the street,"
and Sousa Mendes had this very dramatic,
what he described later
as a nervous breakdown.
He went into his bed for two days.
He got up, and he said,
"I'm gonna give a visa
to anyone who wants it,"
he said, "regardless of,"
you know, "who you are,"
and he then issued thousands of visas.
Each visa could often
accommodate a family,
and among the people he
saved were Salvador Dalí,
the entire Habsburg
family, the Rothschilds.
I opened my book
with the saving of the
H.A. and Margret Ray,
who were the authors of "Curious George,"
who were literally carrying
the manuscript with them,
and then he was,
when the door slammed
shut a few weeks later,
he was summoned back to Lisbon.
He was fired.
He had his pension, basically,
dramatically reduced.
He went through his entire life savings.
They were literally burning
the furniture to keep warm.
His wife died prematurely.
He died, he had a stroke,
and then he died premature,
like, a relatively young
age, and his life was ruined,
and I put a couple quotes
from here, you know,
he survived at one point,
and this was a from,
he had been from one of the
wealthiest families in Portugal.
He was going to the Jewish soup kitchen,
and a teenager working
there remembered later
he saw him, and he was in his,
you know, diplomatic garb,
but it was very threadbare,
and he said to him, he
saw him with his family,
they had the Jewish part
of the soup kitchen,
and they had a part for
Portuguese, which was nice.
He said, "Come to this part,
and you're not a refuge."
Sousa Mendes says, "We're all refugees,"
and he had this amazing
line, also, where he said,
when he made the decision to do this,
knowing that he was gonna
be in trouble for it later,
he said, "I would rather
stand with God against man
"than with man against God,"
so he's one of my rescuers.
I tell this story, which
is, like, totally different,
but I just found it so
fascinating, the circus,
and this goes to kind of that creativity,
so the circus is actually a
very multicultural industry.
It's also a family business,
so whenever you go to the
circus, they tell you, you know,
this acrobat troupe was
like the ninth generation,
and, you know, hundred years ago,
a lot of the circuses were Jewish,
and they also were intermarried
with non-Jewish circus people,
and there was a family
called the Lorch family
that invented, you know,
if you've ever seen someone lean back
and kind of, like, juggle a person,
that was their famous act,
and they were the highest paid.
You could see that in
the poster on the left,
the highest single paid attraction.
They were the star of
the Ringling Bros. and Barnum
& Bailey Circus in New York,
and in the '30s, the Nazis
started to, you know,
basically persecute the Jewish circus,
and then, eventually
starting to round them up
and deport them to death camps.
The girl on the right in the picture
was an acrobat who was a teenager,
and she was a member of this family,
and when things got very scary,
she approached these two people,
Adolf Althoff on the
left, and his wife Maria,
who were circus owners,
and who, like many circus
owners, were performers,
and they
and his siblings did something similar,
but they hid her in the circus,
and not only did they hide her,
she performed in the circus,
and then they ended up
hiding her entire family.
She fell in love with a clown,
and they ended up having
two children during the war,
so they were rescuing six
people in plain sight,
and it was a traveling circus,
and everywhere it went,
they would have to be
inspected by the Gestapo,
and Althoff would tell these stories
about performing in
Russia with dancing bears,
and somehow they managed
to keep this going
throughout the entire war,
and saved this Jewish family
of performers.
Very briefly, Greece, you know,
kind of an unknown story
in the sense that people know
that 95% of the Jews
of Greece were killed.
That was the worst
survival rate in Europe,
but in the South,
that was mostly in
Salonica, on Thessaloniki,
where there was a Sephardic community,
but in the South there
was a third kind of Jew,
not an Ashkenazi or a Sephardic,
but Romaniote, who were there
since Alexander the Great,
and they actually had a great,
much greater survival rate,
largely because of the
church and civil society.
The man in the middle,
who at one point later
became acting prime minister,
was the Archbishop of Athens
and the head of the Greek Orthodox Church.
He is the only member of a church,
a head of a church to formally
protest the Holocaust,
and on the right was the
chief of police of Athens,
and they led a very large
and very wide-ranging effort
to rescue Jews.
They issued baptismal certificates.
They issued citizenship
papers under false names,
and so the Jews of...
It was also helpful that, you know,
people, some somewhat unknown,
that often in
wherever the Italians
were the occupying force,
which was in the South,
they didn't do roundups,
and the trouble came when the,
after 1943, when the Italians surrendered,
and Germans came into the north of Italy.
That's when the problem,
the roundups started,
and so the Jews that had made it to Athens
had the little, you know,
they had a head start,
and then these people were quite heroic.
On the left, I will point out,
there is a book you may
be familiar with right now
that came out around the same time as mine
by a prince, Prince Harry.
I don't know if, you know,
I've read excerpts from it,
but to me, much more interesting story
is his great-grandmother,
who's on the left,
who is Princess Alice.
She was Prince Philip's mother,
so she's King Charles's grandmother.
She was a great-granddaughter
of Queen Victoria,
which made her a relative
of pretty much all royalty in Europe.
Her cousin was the kaiser,
her aunt was the czarina,
and she, during the war,
hid a family of Jews,
well, a mother and two of her children,
the rest of the brothers had
actually made it to freedom
and were fighting the Nazis,
but she hid this family for
several years in her palace
opposite the Gestapo.
If they had found her,
she would've been executed on the spot.
She was a great hero.
The story is little known,
even in "The Crown."
They didn't really talk
very much about it.
They made her out to be a little
bit of a kook, like, crazy.
She's actually buried in Israel,
for different reasons,
not because of this,
but she's been honored at Yad Vashem,
and I tell her story in the book,
and I hope people find it
at least as interesting as Harry,
but she was a real heroine,
and a real humanitarian.
She operated orphanages
throughout the war,
and was just a great person.
I talked a little bit about Italy.
This is another fascinating story.
Gino Bartali, on the left,
was one of the most famous
athletes in Europe at the time,
and particularly in Italy.
He won the Tour de France in 1938,
and when he did that, you know,
sports were externally
important to Mussolini.
He just liked to show
himself as a great sportsman.
They had won the World Cup.
Everybody dedicated their victory to him.
Bartali refused to do so.
He was a devout Catholic,
and he did two things.
He hid the family you see on the right
in a basement of an apartment
that he owned in Florence,
and he had some other people as well,
and then he was part of,
there's a picture of Assisi,
what was called the Assisi Underground,
and he would bike with
false identity papers,
which were lifesaving,
and because he was so
famous, nobody bothered him,
and he was also had an excuse
to be biking hundreds of miles
throughout the north of Italy,
from Genova to Florence to Rome to Assisi.
Assisi was sort of the center of this,
where they were hiding a
lot of Jews and partisans
in the cloisters, actually,
and so he, they think he
saved several hundred people
as part of that underground did,
and he never told anybody
other than his son.
He didn't want anybody to know about it,
and he said, you know, you don't,
good is something you do,
and you don't talk about,
and he said that, you know,
in life, you win bicycle
races, they give you medals,
and he said there are other medals
that are pinned to your soul,
and you get those in the next life,
so he was, I mean, just
a fascinating story
about one of the most famous
athletes in, you know,
in Europe at the time.
This is also, you know, interesting.
I'll go a little bit more quickly.
On the right is a consul named Sugihara
and his wife,
who was a consul from Japan
that was posted in Lithuania
where there are no Japanese people.
He was really an intelligence officer,
and he was there to
monitor troop movements
because the Japanese were convinced
the Russians and the Germans
would go to war with each other,
and similar to Sousa Mendes,
he had a lineup all of a sudden
of Jews outside of his home,
which was also the consulate.
He ended up issuing
thousands of visas as well,
and many Jews escaped,
many religious Jews.
I've had the experience with Sugihara of,
since I've started talking
and writing about him,
there are at least six people
I know who are actually,
that I knew before,
who I had no idea were
actually rescued by him,
so he was another...
Diplomats, in general, had
an opportunity to help.
Very few of them did, but he
was certainly one of them,
and again, you know, a
citizen of the world.
He was fluent in Russian,
and he was both a Foreign
Service officer and a spy,
and you can see,
I mean, he worked 18-hour
days writing visas like this,
which are almost, you know,
it's like calligraphy,
and so his hand, I mean,
there's stories of him,
like, not even being
able to move his hand,
and he wrote visas until he was recalled,
and was still writing them
on the platform of the train station.
This is Irena Sendler.
I'm gonna go more quickly
so we don't just conscious of time,
but she was 29 years
old social worker 4'11".
She was part of a network.
She went in and out of the
Warsaw ghetto almost daily.
She saved 2,500 small children
and infants and teenagers
and was arrested, tortured.
She survived, but also kept,
once the ghetto, Warsaw ghetto,
where there was, like,
enormously inhumane conditions
was destroyed,
she then continued to monitor
and follow these children
until the end of the war,
and she kept a list of all of their names
with the hope that maybe their parents,
who most of whom perished,
would be able to come back with them,
and she would bury it under a apple tree
in her friend's backyard,
so just an amazingly heroic story
was completely unknown
until about 10 years ago.
One thing I just wanted to
touch on is community rescue,
so some people, many people
are familiar with the Danes.
You see on the left the king.
From the king on down,
there's a apocryphal story
that the king wore a star of David.
He didn't because the Danes
would not permit a Star of
David to be worn by the Jews,
and the Nazis from the
day of the occupation,
the Danes refused to any
discrimination against the Jews.
It's pretty remarkable of the parliament,
they left the government in place.
The Fascist Party regularly
got less than 2% of the vote,
and so the Jews were
left alone for a while,
and then finally got up to
Hitler, who ordered a roundup.
A member of the German government there
actually tipped off the Danish government,
and the entire, almost the entire country,
from taxi drivers and medical students
to I talk about an Olympic rower,
rowed as kind of like a Dunkirk,
almost the entire Jewish population,
7,200 people plus 800 spouses,
to safety in Sweden,
and they actually,
the Nazis caught about 500 who
were sent to Theresienstadt,
and the government of Denmark
regularly called to check on them,
and they were eventually released,
and so only 50 Danish Jews
didn't survive the war.
Another place that
where I talked about
the young man earlier,
this is Le Chambon,
which was in the
Protestant area of France.
They themselves were mostly
descendants of Huguenots,
and there's a long history
of being a place of refuge
from persecution.
They had already hosted some people
from the Spanish Civil War.
It was really a group effort.
Probably the driving force
is the couple you see on the left,
the Pastor Trocmé and his wife,
who was an Italian aristocrat.
Trocmé was actually from the North.
He was from a wealthy family.
He had spent time in New York.
He was the tutor to the Rockefellers,
and then he was sent to
this very poor village,
and they saved about 5,000 people,
3,500 Jewish children, many
of whom had lost their parents
and were taken out of
French internment camps
in a network with French relief
and the American Quakers,
and it was pretty amazing.
I actually had the opportunity
to talk to the little girl on
the right, who's still around,
and who is their daughter,
and was actually a teenager
when this was going on,
and what you can see here,
there are many pictures
in the Holocaust Museum and elsewhere,
is that a lot of the children
that were hidden here,
because there were more than one school,
and there were, the villagers,
they really tried to make
this a normal life for them,
and even when there would
be, you know, raids,
they would send them to the forest,
and say, "We're gonna go pick mushrooms,"
and the children all felt very safe.
There was no instance of betrayal,
and they, most of them talk about,
I've spoken to some of
them, that they really felt
like they had a very normal experience.
They had as close as you could
get in those circumstances
to, you know, a normal childhood.
A lot of them, like, viewed
it as being in summer camp,
and they were, you know, it
was a Protestant village,
but the Jewish children were,
they even had, like, a Hanukkah party
and High Holiday services,
and there was no attempt
to convert anybody,
and there was even a
sect there, Darbyists,
who viewed it as the
Jews as the chosen people
and were very honored
to be protecting them,
but you see here, again,
they're, like, normal life.
I put this in because I know
there's some experts on Camus.
He was next door within walking distance
writing "The Plague,"
and happy to answer
any questions about it.
There were always rumors he knew Trocmé.
I did a little bit of research on this,
and I can say that there were,
they had a lot of friends in common,
and it's pretty clear that
what was going on in Le Chambon
did have an impact on "The Plague."
Talked a little bit about the, you know,
kind of group rescue.
I'm gonna, you know, just skip
through this a little bit.
I wrote an article about
this for "The Journal,"
you know, again, why did
places like Denmark or Albania,
the only majority Muslim
country in Europe,
which had more Jews at the end of the war
than at the beginning, do this?
And again, it was a number
of things that came together,
but the most important thing was
they had no tradition
of religious bigotry.
They stood together against the Nazis,
and they often had some ethos, you know,
whether it was religion.
Besa is a Albanian culture,
a ethos of hospitality
that brought them together,
and one thing I would just say
is that community matters.
There was a Dutch rescuer,
which had a mixed record, but
was better than other places,
who said, you know, "We, the extreme,"
like, "the people that were
willing to risk our lives
"were the tip of the spear,
"but what really made a
difference was people willing to,
"our neighbors looked the other way
"or they were quietly supportive,"
and so I think that is an
extremely important lesson
is to have a culture
that doesn't tolerate,
you know, the bigotry,
or even kind of
where people stand up
when they see somebody being
mistreated and say something,
and where that's not valued.
I think who and what we value as a society
is critical to preventing
anything like this
ever happening again,
so happy to kind of, you
know, circle back to that.
I just, before we go to Q&A,
I just wanted to do one
Yale thing, which is
many of you may be
familiar with Varian Fry,
who was sent to, he was sent
because of this picture,
which is the very famous
writer, Lion Feuchtwanger,
who was here behind barbed wire,
and Eleanor Roosevelt saw this picture,
and it was one of the catalysts
that ended up creating the
Emergency Rescue Committee,
which is now the IRC,
and they sent Fry over to
try to rescue with a list,
many of the most famous artists, writers,
political thinkers in Europe,
and he did so over 13 months
before he was expelled,
kind of at the behest
of the State Department,
and, you know, here he is with
a bunch of the surrealists,
and he's in the middle in a villa
that he rented outside of Marseilles,
and he was part, and so they, you know,
what a amazing gift and
single-handedly because of him,
you know, the center of, you know,
art and literature and culture
moved from Europe to the United States.
You can make that argument.
Here he is with Marc Chagall and his wife
looking at a painting,
and I just wanted to point out
that the tall guy in the back
is a Yalie who was
instrumental to the rescue,
and his name is Hiram Bingham IV,
so his father was the Hiram
Bingham III from Machu Picchu.
He was the governor and
senator from Connecticut.
He himself was a horrible
racist and anti-Semite,
which makes, I think, what
Harry did even more remarkable,
so Harry was the Yale class of '25,
went to Harvard Law School,
entered the Foreign Service,
and was the vice consul in Marseilles
in 1940 when the Nazis invaded,
and he was instrumental in helping Fry
and the entire group of people
around Fry do what they did
because he issued visas, but
he also hid people in his home.
There's stories of him
pulling people out of internment camps.
He rescued hundreds of people,
including Chagall and Feuchtwanger,
but Heinrich Mann, André Breton,
Max Ernst, Lipchitz,
like, almost the entire,
you know, surrealist group.
He also inspected and wrote up reports
on the conditions in the
French internment camps,
and he, for his efforts,
was basically
transferred to Portugal
and then sent to Argentina
when he started to tell people
in the State Department,
you know, there's a lot of, like,
Nazis and gold flowing into Argentina.
They moved them to Cuba,
which was basically a
backwater at the time,
kind of forced him out
of the Foreign Service,
and he had a similarly
sad kind of decline,
although he didn't die, you know,
early, the way Sousa Mendes
did, but had a sad life,
and Fry actually, when he wrote his book,
he inscribed the copy to Bingham,
"My partner in the crime
of saving human lives,"
and Fry has been honored.
I actually think his entire
group should be honored,
and Bingham was on a U.S. postage stamp,
and he's received some other awards,
but he's not been honored by Yad Vashem,
and he's not been honored
by the State Department.
Colin Powell gave a citation for the group
that's for retired State
Department employees,
but there was a bill entered
into Congress last week
to honor 60 diplomats with a gold medal,
and Bingham is on the list.
He's the only American,
but a very, you know,
underappreciated figure
who just, you know, even,
there are families that
would still, to this day,
light a candle in his honor,
Jewish families every
year for what he did,
and then, if you look at the gift
that he and Fry and the group around them
gave to America is pretty remarkable,
so I couldn't resist,
you know, mentioning him
because he deserves to be known,
and (indistinct) more, you know,
his hundredth anniversary of
his graduation is coming up,
so, you know, Yale should be proud of him.
- Thank you. Thank you so
much, Richard, for that.
Really, you know, great
talk and for the book.
I really think it's such an important
and so important to remember these people
in the way that you do,
so really moving and interesting,
so a lot of questions,
and there are a lot of
questions from the audience,
so we don't have that much time,
so we'll just try to do as many as we can.
First of all, just wondering what kind of,
how you did your research for this.
What kind of research went into the book?
Did you travel around?
Did you interview people?
Was it mostly secondary research?
- No, it was, I mean, of course,
you always do secondary research,
but I did a lot of primary
research in a lot of archives.
Yad Vashem is particularly helpful
because any time anyone gets the award,
there's, you know, eyewitness testimony
and a lot of documents that go into it,
so we did, I think we must have done,
I say we 'cause I had
some help on translation,
probably 12 different languages,
and I also had the opportunity
to interview a number of survivors,
most of whom were children,
and then, I had a fascinating experience
interviewing a lot of
children of rescuers-
- Oh, tell us a little bit about that.
I assume that no rescuers,
you weren't able to talk to any
rescuers?
- No, there,
no, but there was,
there were, you know,
interviews with a lot of them.
Actually, I owe Manuscripts
and Archives a thanks
because during Covid there was
a documentary that was made
and all the footage is at Yale,
and they put it up online for me,
and actually Bingham had a long interview,
and I ended up sending it to,
I interviewed three of his children.
They had not heard their
father's voice since the '80s,
and so they were, like,
profoundly touched by hearing it.
I mean, the mix, I found
it really interesting
because the children,
it's mixed, you know.
Bingham's children view
him kind of as a saint.
Fry's son, who I spoke to,
said his father had a lot of issues,
which has, I think, come out now,
and he thought he was bipolar, you know,
didn't have a close
relationship with him at all.
He was sort of negative.
I mean, even the Trocmés'
daughter, you know,
who had these parents that
were almost, you know,
they were very prominent
in the nonviolent movement
when they knew Gandhi, they
knew Martin Luther King,
they were heroic.
She said, "Yeah, we were
saving all these Jews,
"and they were good parents,
"but like, you know, they
never came to our piano recital
"'cause they didn't have time,"
and, you know, like, things like that,
and, you know, people had
illegitimate children, you know,
and I think, you know,
but on the other hand,
it made them seem real.
I mean, these weren't
people like Mother Teresa
who set out to be
righteous with their lives.
They found themselves in this situation,
and they acted in a certain way,
and they had flaws, like all of us,
which I think makes it hopeful.
- Yeah, exactly.
I mean, it's so important to show that
because if everyone is just a saint,
you think, "Oh, I can never,"
you know, "become like-"
- No, they were quite the opposite.
They were multidimensional,
complicated people.
- So how do you account for
the fact that if, as you said,
religious belief was one of
the contributing factors,
that there were so few actual, you know,
like, how do you account
for the Catholic Church's,
you know, relative lack of
participation in saving Jews?
- Yeah, I mean, well, I
think, first of all, you know,
there's a whole debate
over the pope, right?
And his predecessor was about
to come out with a statement
denouncing anti-Semitism in Germany,
and he died,
and so I think part of it was at the top.
I mean, the church is not a monolith,
so the Bartali story shows that, you know,
that these part of the church,
and the main movers there
were the Archbishop of Florence and Genova
and the Bishop of Assisi,
and a lot of the, you know,
the clergy really participated,
but, again, I think it
has to do with, you know,
why you belong to a church
or why you, you know,
so again, people who are
really into hierarchy
or who are into, I mean,
the way the church acted was, you know,
similar to the Foreign Service
in a lot of ways, you know,
rule-followers and hierarchy,
people attracted to that,
but people who really internalized
the teachings of whatever faith,
and again, they often
got that from a parent
or maybe from the local
priest they grew up with.
They tended to be, you know,
I mean, the people in Le
Chambon were Protestants,
and they were very devout.
One of the people who
was there said, you know,
they didn't read the newspaper every day,
but they knew their Bible,
and there was a lot of Bible study,
so I think if it was a more personal faith
tended to be more correlated with rescue.
- Okay, and I'll just encourage
people to submit questions
using the Q&A function at
the bottom of your screen,
and I'll take a question
from the audience, which is,
"Did you find examples
"of rescuers who cooperated
"or who formed networks," you know,
"even," you know, "across Europe?
"Or was it pretty much,"
like, "an individual thing?"
- No, it was both,
so you had individual people,
like the Althoffs.
You had countries like Denmark, you know,
Irena Sendler in Poland
for example, was operating.
She put together a network of,
like, Jewish friends in the ghetto
and non-Jewish friends out of the ghetto,
and after a while, they merged
with something called Żegota,
which was a very large
underground organization
set up to save Jews by two women,
one of whom was a liberal democrat,
one of whom was an anti-Semite,
but who didn't believe you
should exterminate Jews,
and that was funded by the
Polish government in exile
and the Allies.
There were people like Bartali,
who hid people in his basement by himself,
but it also was part of
the Assisi Underground,
so, you know,
there were, again,
there were a lot of people
all over Europe who were,
not a lot, but of the rescuers
who were people who were
hiding people in their homes.
I mean, that was, like, the
most common fact pattern,
but then, there were,
whenever there was a large-scale rescue,
often, it was part of a,
it would part of some
kind of organized network.
- And, you know, I would,
someone in the audience
who I know well pointed out
that Yale's Fortunoff Archive
of Holocaust Testimony
also has a lot of testimonies of rescuers,
so not just of survivors,
and that's an incredible resource.
Is that something that you
made use of in your research?
- Yeah, I mean, the video
testimony is really important,
so I did,
and then, also the Shoah
project, USC Shoah project.
I mean, they had a fascinating interview
with a guy who was a
counterfeiter for Bartali
who was Jewish,
and he talked about,
so those are, yeah,
those are very important,
and unfortunately, you
know, like, you know,
as we were talking about, many
people are no longer with us,
so it's really the only way we can,
but the first, obviously,
first-person testimony
is the most important.
- Mm-hmm, and here,
someone in the audience
asked what I think is,
you know, the question,
which is, "Does learning
about these rescuers
"inspire other people to do the same?"
It seems like that's where
you're kind of heading,
but do you have any kind of proof of that?
Or is it just a hope?
- Well, it's hard to,
like, I don't have any
example of someone saying,
"I did this because," you
know, "Wallenberg inspired me,"
but I can tell you
that the outpouring I've gotten from,
like, a reaction to articles I've written
or even starting from the book
would say to me, "Yes, I think most people
"want to believe that
they would've done this."
I don't know how many of us would have.
I mean, it's one thing to risk your career
or to be inconvenienced.
It's another thing to risk your life,
and then, it's another thing
to risk your, like, children's life,
which some people in parts of Europe did,
and that's very extreme,
and I don't think it's
very hard for us to judge,
but I do think
what I hope is that the
inspiration of these people
would make all of us
be more like the people that helped them,
that created the atmosphere
that allowed this to happen
because that's where you really need
to have a lot of people,
but no, I do think people
are very inspired by them,
and I think, you know,
we're not living through World War II,
but there's lots of pain in the world,
and there's lots that we can do,
and you can make a difference
just, again, by standing
up to someone being bullied
or by helping, you know, support,
like, you know, things going
on overseas that are horrific
and speaking out on that,
and that's all important.
- Yeah, that kind of leads to a question
that I had, you know, written down also,
which is, you know,
there's so many atrocities going on
that we hear about all the time
from, like, you know, child
labor to police killings
to, you know, what's
going on at the border,
and, you know, how do you avoid
just feeling overwhelmed
and paralyzed, you know?
So you don't have, you're
not actually, you know,
you think these things are terrible,
but it's just so overwhelming,
and you think, like, "What
can," you know, "one person do?"
So you just do nothing?
I mean, how do you get past that?
Do you have any
insight?
- Yeah, I would say,
I mean, I think, you know,
the very famous statement, you know,
he who saves one life
saves the world, right?
Is very profound in a lot of ways.
I mean, one is that, I mean,
I've experienced that by meeting
descendants of, you know,
like, there's probably
a million people alive
because of actions taken in the,
just the 10 stories in
my book today, right?
'Cause of just the descendants,
but also, anything that you
do makes a difference, right?
So, I mean, in Afghanistan
I know a lot of people
that were involved with rescuing people
and just getting one person
out, you know, to that.
There's a story a friend of mine
put in his book on Afghanistan
where, you know, a little
boy is walking along a beach,
and he sees all these starfish washed up,
and they're dying because
they need to be in the water,
and he picks up one, and
he throws it back in,
and an older man comes over to him
and says, "Why did you do," like,
like, "that's not gonna
make a difference,"
and he says, "Well, made
a difference to that one,"
so yeah, I mean, the world is,
and we have much more information
about what's going on now
on an ongoing basis,
but I think, again, I've heard, you know,
Abe Foxman, who's a friend,
when he spoke at my daughter's school,
he said, you know, like,
just, again, like, you know,
"Starting by standing up for somebody,"
like, I think, you know,
that anti-bullying campaign is actually,
people make fun of it, but it's real,
so, you know, but, you know, we, again,
supporting people, also,
who are out there on the
front lines doing something
is really important
because not everybody,
you can't do everything all of the time,
nor should we expect ourselves to do that,
but we can all have a big
effect on the culture,
and again, I would like
to see people today
who are doing amazing
things much more celebrated.
I mean, like, I'm not saying
we shouldn't have, you know,
think like sports people,
and, like, the Grammys is fun,
but we should also add into that
just as much acknowledging
people who are, you know,
doing things to help people in Ukraine
or with this earthquake yesterday
or, you know, other things like that.
We don't do enough of that.
That's not who we value as
the media and as a society.
- Okay, you know, there's
so many other questions
and people had, like, very specific things
about, you know, specific rescuers,
and, you know, unfortunately,
we are out of time.
I would love to have, you know,
been able to ask you
all of these questions,
but I think it's really
a sign that, you know,
your book is really, you know,
you know, resonating with
people, and that's great, so-
- Well, people should
feel free to e-mail me
if they have
questions or-
- Yeah, could you say where,
how they would reach you?
- Sure, yeah, no.
My e-mail's rhurowitz@octavian.com,
but you can also find it.
I have a writing website,
which is my name, richardhurowitz.com.
You can e-mail me there,
or I'm on LinkedIn or Twitter.
- Okay. Terrific.
Thank you, and this presentation
was recorded,
and it'll be posted on the Y-P-S-A,
YPSA website soon,
so if people, you know,
missed it, you know,
please feel free to direct
them to our website,
and also, I really encourage everybody
to make sure that you're
on the YPSA mailing list
because we do a lot of programs like this,
and, you know, it would be great
to see you at future events,
which we have, you know,
several more this semester,
which are really interesting,
so please join me in thanking Richard
for this really great presentation.
Unfortunately, you can't see
everyone clapping for you,
but I will
clap.
- Maury, thank you.
Thank you for having me,
and it's just very meaningful
to have a conversation at Yale for me,
so thank you for hosting me.
- Terrific, and thank you
to all of you for coming.
Bye.